foreign
hello uh take it away we're taking only
questions from Instagram the tally
Starts Now go Jordan okay we got one
from Andrea here how do you prioritize
paying off the house versus saving for
kids college when both seem urgent oh
that's an interesting one well it
depends on the kid's age if they're
about to go to college let's focus on
making sure they go to college debt free
if the kids are one year old and you can
start saving in an Esa or 529 then I'm
okay putting more of that margin onto
the house so it all depends on how old
the kids are how urgent it is how
expensive the schooling is but do it
debt free
ammo step three I'm a stay-at-home mom
wanting to make extra money I teach
memory tricks to kids I teach on uh I'm
not going to try to endorse anything
well so she teaches on an online
platform how do I stand out okay here's
how you stand out you stand out by doing
a really really good job of helping one
student then the next student then the
next student then the next student you
know so many times the entrepreneurs
people that want to start something on
the side you're trying to go big and the
only way you go big is by being good so
be good for one two three four don't
worry about scaling it keep showing up
and keep delivering don't despise humble
beginnings by the way we're up to two
now all right Cameron asks Which single
stock or crypto should I invest in that
one is easy neither neither don't invest
in these volatile Investments stick to
the boring stuff like mutual funds index
funds your 401k your Roth IRAs do not
mess with single stocks or crypto your
life is too important uh Chris Wimmer
says what career advice do you have for
someone retiring from the military this
year after 20 your career well first of
all Chris thank you for your service to
our country you are a great American
second I want you to be looking into
your military career for collusion
Direction specifically what skills did
you acquire and deliver on in the
military in 20 years secondly what
experience that you have in the military
of 20-year career can you translate over
to the private sector a lot of people
who retire from the military George feel
like it's not transferable your skills
and experience are transferable the
final piece is what type of work did you
really love and if you didn't love any
type of work what kind of work do you
really want to do how do your skills and
experience set you up and if you need
some additional qualification go do it
but you can do it and you should again
thank you Chris beautifully said we've
got one from
tgrndkie we want to start the baby steps
but we need help with budgeting where do
we start well it's super easy Go
download the every dollar app and it
will walk you through how to set up your
budget you can do this online as well
everydollar.com your list out your
income followed by your expenses your
income minus expenses should equal zero
we call that a zero base budget and that
helps you start to figure out as you
track it do we need to make some Cuts
how do we find more margin do we need
more income that's what Ken helps you do
as well and so that's going to be a
great start message me I can send you
some resources on that as well all right
next is uh Mega Neva Joyce boy that's a
tough one not sure if that's
phonetically correct but that's my shot
my annual review is coming up in a few
months any tips on boosting my chances
for a decent raise like that well let me
tell you this you can't help your boss
determine how much you will get that's
going to be over your head here's what
you want to do you want to set yourself
up to where you're having an current and
an ongoing conversation about a race and
we don't ask for a raise George we ask
for a growth plan it looks like this
here's the conversation Hey listen I
really like being here and I want to
continue to grow here and specifically
I'd like you as my leader to help me
develop a growth plan that includes what
are some things that I could be doing
better in my current role two what are
some skills and experience that I could
add to my tool belt to make me more
valuable and in three how do we measure
that so that I can get more
responsibility and more compensation I'd
like to let you write that out for me
let's get together on this because I
want to be held accountable because I
want to win that's how you go after the
race that's a good one all right back to
a money question from David Busby do you
count maxing out an HSA as part of the
15 percent that we talk about maybe step
four I Max my Roth contribute to a 401k
but would like to Max the HSA next love
the question HSA is a health savings
account and it's not part of your 15 of
investing for retirement in baby step
four because it only can be used towards
qualified medical expenses so your HVAC
goes out you need a car repair done well
you can't use your HSA and so we're not
going to count that but I love the idea
of maxing it out but only once you are
in baby step seven because the rest of
the margin you still need to pay off the
house early you need to start saving for
kids college so there's a time and place
for it but big fan of the HSA Lisa x 97
asks is it realistic to start a second
career after retiring from your first
career at 50. yes it's realistic in fact
I think it'd be a lot of fun what a fun
journey to take that first career and
the skills and experience that you've
Acquired and then put it to something
that you actually have always wanted to
do because you don't have to work now
you get to work I say go for it you
still have many chapters left to right I
love that one uh here's a fun one advice
for newlyweds with finances from Caleb
well number one getting on the same page
with money that is the foundation of all
of this if you're not on the same page
you're going different directions it's
not going to end well so number one do a
budget together and you both need to
have a say in what goes into the budget
and so one person can kind of own it but
you got to make tweaks to it the free
Spirits the Nerds need to come together
on this and number two set of vision and
set goals for both of you not just one
of you where do we want to see ourselves
five years from now we want to be out of
debt we want to have a paid for house we
want to get the down payment whatever
that is be aiming towards that together
and have fun make sure that you both
have some fun money in the budget for
each of you to enjoy to do the things
you love to do James how many questions
are we up to so far that was nine so
yeah okay we need a little fun one here
okay this is uh very relevant right now
uh this is from Courtney gwyn09 pumpkin
pie or pecan pie George you first pecan
for me pecan for me and a dollop of
whipped cream on top just a dollop just
no more no less just a dollar oh this is
a fun one for you Ken does maintaining a
LinkedIn really matter and yes my name
is link that's comes from a guy named
link oh link who wants to know what he
should do on LinkedIn well link you
should be on LinkedIn I think it's a
wonderful wonderful tool for connection
and information but don't rely only on
the uh the messaging format from
LinkedIn because here's the deal
everybody's there for the same reason
largely for themselves nothing wrong
with that however if you just rely eye
on the LinkedIn messaging to connect to
somebody you might get ignored because
let's be honest everybody's busy so
here's what I want use the information
from LinkedIn to make a real life
connection I know where they work so I
can figure out I can write a handwritten
note and mail it I can call I can set up
a meaning all the good stuff so don't
rely completely on the messaging but yes
you should be there here's one from SC
fishing what's a good emergency fund
amount for an 80 000 annual income well
the way we look at emergency funds is
three to six months of expenses and so
the income isn't as relevant of a piece
of this equation and so start to look at
hey what does it take for us to live in
a single given month for our basic
expenses then we can multiply that out
and if you're if you've got risky a
regular income you're a single income
and you've got two people I would lean
it towards the six months if you got two
stable jobs not a lot of health concerns
then you can lean it towards that three
months and so it all comes down to your
expenses what would it take for you to
survive in a given month and multiply
that out real quick before we get to our
maybe one more question here if all you
people saying it's pecan you're wrong
all right and go back to where you can
it's not pecan it's pecan raise these
people I don't know what's happening in
the world today uh Holly Laris 28 says
should I stay at a job I hate when my
husband and I are a month away from
starting the home buying process now uh
you've got two separate questions here
should you stay in a job you hate no
should you stay in that job until you
replace it because you're in the home
buying process yes but do not leave the
job unless you have something to leave
too uh you can hang in there a little
bit longer until you replace it but
don't leave it uh without stepping into
something else can I just end with this
one Derek Miller said Ken is a gangster
and I just want to point out how that is
categorically false not true yeah I mean
Furthest Thing from gangster there is is
me keep in mind that's what I said
earlier you ever known a gangster to use
the word dollop I don't think so also
one more Braden Wilson George he says
ham or turkey what say you sir oh I'm
going am all day long no sir turkey get
a better nap out of that